hallo ihr lieben wir machen heute die
leckere klassische linzertorte wie ich
darauf kam das habe ich euch zu
verdanken denn ich habe euch wo
regionale gefragt was verbindet ihr mit
euren lieblings winter rezepten und dann
kamen ganz oft die antwort die linzer
torte und deswegen machen wir jetzt und
dafür zeige ich euch zuallererst den
richtig schönen leckeren mürbeteig dafür
benötigen wir gemahlene nüsse ich habe
jetzt man den genommen außerdem mehl
zucker in stückchen geschnittene butter
ließ kalt
außerdem zimtpulver und netten pulver
und für den leckeren mürbeteig werden
jetzt ganz einfach alle gerade
vorgestellten zutaten in die
küchenmaschine gegeben natürlich geht es
auch mit der hand aber das ist jetzt
einfach für faule ich geb's zu heute bin
ich ein bisschen faul und das tolle ist
dass bei dem mürbeteig ein teil des
mehls durch mangel- oder haselnüsse
generell in welche gemeinde müsse
ersetzt wird und dadurch wieder noch mal
richtig schön mürbe
[Musik]
und sobald ihr merkt das ganze ist
richtig schön fest geworden könnt ihr
das ganze aus der maschine nehmen ich
möchte das jetzt noch mal für ein paar
sekunden auf der arbeitsfläche und dann
wird das ganze gekühlt
so als nächstes wird der teig schön in
frischhaltefolie verpackt das drückt das
noch schön flach damit er schön durch
kühlen kann dann kommt für eine halbe
stunde in den kühlschrank und dann sehen
wir uns wieder der tag ist jetzt gut
durch gekühlte ist nicht ganz hart wie
bei meinem text zeigt also da ist schon
noch weg sein aber eben durch gekühlt
und so können wir besser arbeiten und
als nächstes nimmt ihr euch eure springt
form ich habe jetzt eine 26 cm springt
vom 24 und 28 gehen auch dann wird er
eben höher oder ein bisschen tiefer und
ihr könnt euren backen verwenden ist
vollkommen euch überlassen
ich habe den hier noch einmal gefällt
mit weicher butter und werden jetzt noch
mit ein bisschen mehl aus klein
[Musik]
sollen jetzt packe ich mir meinen teig
aus und nimmt hier zwei drittel des
tages wird damit den boden und die
seiten der springform auskleiden und
dann machen wir das schöne gittermuster
das zeige ich euch aber dann
[Musik]
und für die seiten mache ich das also
ich mache es mir gerne einfach sagen wir
mal so ich rolle mir einen strang auf
der arbeitsfläche nehme ihn dann und
gibt ihnen dann an den rand der
springform und dann könnte das ja ganz
einfach hochdrücken
[Musik]
für der boden und die ränder sind jetzt
vorbereitet als nächstes kommt unsere
füllung ins spiel und dafür nimmt jetzt
eine konfitüre eurer wahl ich persönlich
rate euch nimmt eine die nicht zu süß
ist denn ihr habt viel konfitüre
eigentlich ist es ja die komplette
füllung wenn es immer schöner wenn sie
so ein bisschen milder ist ich habe hier
schwarze johannisbeere genommen und
verteilt das jetzt einmal auf dem boden
[Musik]
das ist soweit vorbereitet und das gebe
ich jetzt auch an die seite
denn jetzt kommt unsere gitter form und
die machen wir jetzt mit dem übrig
gebliebenen teile ich da ein bisschen
mehl auf die arbeitsfläche damit auch
nichts an klebt und dann einfach schön
ausräumen
[Musik]
das habe ich jetzt soweit ausgerollt das
ist so ungefähr ein halber zentimeter
dick und jetzt schneiden wir uns
streifen aus da müsste einfach selber
entscheiden wichtig oder wie jersey
möglich entscheidet jetzt ganz spontan
meine werden für eineinhalb zentimeter
breit so nicht einfach durch schneiden
mit dem pizza roller
und jetzt jetzt ein bisschen knifflig
jetzt nehmen wir uns unsere streifen und
legen sie als gitter muss da oben drauf
[Musik]
und das was von euren streifen jetzt
über steht also zum rand hin dass könnt
ihr ganz einfach abschneiden
[Musik]
so dass gittermuster ist fertig das
sieht schon richtig schick aus und den
restlichen tag habe ich nur noch so ein
bisschen übrig daraus mache ich gleich
plätzchen also einfach auf steche
plätzchen und jetzt zeige ich euch nur
noch einen ganz entscheidenden schritt
für die optik denn wir nehmen uns jetzt
einen teig schaber da können wir mal
schön an den rand rein und drücken uns
den rand runter dann haben wir nämlich
noch mal so ein schöner abschluss
so jetzt ist der rand auch fertig ich
habe nämlich schon viele arten gesehen
eine linzer torte zu backen und viele
rollen dann auch eine wurst und geben
das dann auch den rand aber so finde ich
persönlich das viel einfacher und als
nächstes nehmen wir uns ein ei das habe
ich verquirlt und bestreichen damit den
rand und das gitter also nicht die
marmelade sondern wirklich nur den teig
[Musik]
also viel vom habe ich jetzt nicht
verbraucht deshalb gibt's gleich auf
jeden fall geplant auf jeden fall wenn
in den linzer torte back oder ersetzt es
einfach durch milch aber dadurch bekommt
noch einmal eine richtig schöne farbe
und jetzt nehmen wir uns gehobelte
mandeln gerne auch gestiftete und gehen
wir einmal an den rand
[Musik]
die linzer torte sieht wie wichtig
richtig hübsch aus aber es geht noch
eine sache zu beachten bitte verspricht
mir dass ihr das nicht außer acht
gebt sie springform so wie sie ist in
den kühlschrank für 30 minuten dann
festigt sich der teig und eure form
bleibt wie sie ist und anschließend geht
es ihr gebt ihr sie erst in den
vorgeheizten backofen ich mich aufgeregt
also so wichtig ist dieser schritt sorgt
bis gleich
[Musik]
und jetzt wünsche ich euch ganz viel
spaß im nachbacken die linzer torte
schmeckt unglaublich fein und total
lecker gerne zum spieljahr sahne und
latte macchiato und ich freue mich wenn
ihr das ganze nach macht die genauen
mengenangaben schreibe ich euch wie
immer unten in die infobox markiert mich
gerne mit dem hashtag s kitchen auf
instagram könnte ich hier gerne ein
kostenloses abo da lassen und ein
bäumchen nach oben darüber freue ich
mich immer sehr und natürlich auch über
euer feedback in den kommentaren und
dann sehen wir uns beim nächsten mal
wieder auf die hieß kitchen tschüss
[Musik]